ja dieser auftritt riecht nach einem
handfesten skandal gestern traten drei
polizisten auf der demonstration aus
bayern auf aber nicht etwa um ihre
kollegen kollegen in berlin zu
unterstützen und ihnen zu hilfe zu eilen
nein sie traten als redner bei den
demonstrationen auf und darüber spreche
jetzt mit peter pytlik vize chef der
polizeigewerkschaft in bayern guten
morgen herr pytlik also polizisten als
corona leutner offenbar was sagen sie
dazu
ja was sagen sie dazu
wir haben uns ja schon geäußert bei den
auftritten in bayern tiefer drei wochen
waren also polizeibeamte in der
öffentlichkeit aufzutreten oder als
polizei kann das ist sehr bedenklich ich
meine natürlich haben auch polizisten
und andere andere oder wie andere das
recht ihre meinung zu äußern und die sie
auch kundzutun
aber man muss schon immer wissen wie das
macht und als und uns wird es macht herr
patrick wie konnte es dazu kommen
sollten da beamte nicht mal kurz
rücksprache halten wenn sie sich
öffentlich auf solchen demonstrationen r
äußern wollen wie es ihre einschätzung
na ja das wäre der richtige und
wünschenswerte weg nur ob dann die
genehmigung kommt bei solchen
demonstrationen sicherung zu äußern und
dann ist immer die frage wie und was ist
der inhalt meiner worte und das würde
jedem kollegen wirklich und erträgen
also dieses jahr genau überprüft und
dann wirklich sagt die dinge wie aus
seiner sicht sind und zumindest keine
angriffe auf den staat und es um stress
unter dem stück seine äußerungen
sie kennen offenbar einen der
beteiligten auch persönlich was geht
ihnen daher durch den kopf und auch
durchs herz was empfinden sie da ist das
unangenehm für sie naja natürlich ist es
unangenehm wenn ein kollege ich sage
jetzt mal sich durch solche auftritte in
geselligen schwierigkeiten
begibt weil der dienstag natürlich
überprüfen muss allerdings auf
ich sage jetzt mal untersuchungen
notwendig natürlich zu transfer weil ein
kollege von uns ist denke ich auch jetzt
zumindest besser endlich am telefon
keine macht sicherlich keinen spaß
wie geht es in diesem fall jetzt weiter
was sind die konsequenzen
naja die konsequenzen wird man so hin
das muss das zuständige polizeipräsidium
mittelfranken dann schließen das wird ja
auch bereits geprüft inwiefern oder zur
maßnahme ist kommen wird des werden
lässt sich derzeit nicht sagen sie es
irgendwie die disziplinarische
ermittlungen ergeben
und weiter möchte ich dazu nicht sagen
weil die sims oder auch nicht so heftig
von der polizeigewerkschaft in bayern
vielen herzlichen dank